hi good morning and good afternoon
everyone welcome to today's webinar a
workflow for knockin genome editing
simplified our presenter today is dr.
matthew polling product manager for
genome editing at Thermo Fisher
Scientific my name is Louise Baskin also
of thermo Fisher Scientific and I'll be
your moderator for today's event today's
educational web seminar is brought to
you by lab roots and sponsored by in
vitro gen by thermo Fisher in be Trojan
offers tools and solutions for every
step in the CRISPR genome editing
workflow for more information please
visit www.dent.umich.edu/license and all
questions that don't get answered live
will receive a written response by email
you'll also see multiple tabs at the top
of the page feel free to click through
those they have related applications
upcoming and related webinars as well as
links to some different resources on the
topics that you'll be hearing about
today also please notice that you can
share this webinar on your personal
social media just click on the social
social sharing tab to let your friends
and colleagues know about today's live
event if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation click on the
support tab that's found at the top
right of the presentation window or you
can report the problem by clicking the
ask a question box this presentation is
educational and offers continuing
education credits so click on the
continuing education credits tab located
at the top right of the presentation
window and then follow the process to
obtain your credits
I'd like to now introduce our presenter
dr. matthew poling matt earned his PhD
in biomedical sciences from UC san diego
and joined Thermo Fisher Scientific in
2015
he's currently the lead product manager
for genome editing technologies and
works very closely with thermo Fisher's
Research and Development scientists to
create innovative genome editing tools
and services so that is all I have to
say Matt I'll go ahead and turn it over
to you for the webinar
thank you for that introduction I will
go ahead and get started with today's
webinar before we get too deep I did
want to take a moment and acknowledge
our genome editing R&D and product
development group that I work very
closely with we're all located in
Carlsbad California and there's a team
of 25 full-time genome editing
scientists that I've partnered with
we're all working to advance tools and
application development around genome
editing working to improve the CRISPR
cassadine and talit vector nucleus
technologies it was specific some
emphasis on functional genomic
applications our Carlsbad site acts as
our R&D hub and a center of excellence
we have a number of different R&D teams
there including our delivery and
transection groups our stem cell biology
team and are able to utilize resources
from our NGS platform as well as our
antibody development and custom services
teams and R&D team here has done a
really a great amount of work here and
I'm going to be displaying a a good
amount of their data today for today's
presentation our agenda will consist of
a review of NOC and genome editing we
will then present the rules for
successful HDR donor design we will
demonstrate how to easily design your
own knockin tools with our true design
genome editor we will then show how to
obtain a hundred percent
edited cells with true tag donors and
then lastly go over to case studies that
apply to tag knock and editing for
pluripotent stem cells and T cells so to
have a quick review of genome editing
what we're trying to accomplish here is
looking at double-stranded DNA that's in
the host of the genome of the cell line
of you're interested in and using an
engineer nucleus to cause a
double-stranded break in that DNA after
that double-stranded break has occurred
we're going to use the cell's natural
repair machinery to repair that
double-stranded break and cause the
genome to be modified in a way that's
relevant for your application type if
you're looking to do gene knockouts this
is done by non-homologous end joining
which will cause in Dells insertions and
deletions that can cause frame shift and
premature stop codon
in your gene of interest this is done to
produce knockout cell models as well as
jus genomic screenings the second
pathway is to do gene insertions or
knock ends by HDR and this is a little
bit different than what's done for gene
knockouts and that includes a donor
molecule with left and right homology
arms flanking your insertion sequence
that would get incorporated into the
genome these kind of knock ends are used
to add reporters to genes create fusion
proteins disrupt functional domains or
change snips to mimic disease models and
this naki an approach is going to be the
main focus of our presentation today for
a knock in edit there are a number of
required materials that are needed first
a specific and efficient nuclea system
second a repair template with the
desired change that you want to have
incorporated into the genome and third a
method to deliver these material into
yourself and for today's presentation
we're going to focus on number one and
number two specifically we'll talk about
different types of specific and
efficient nuclea systems as well as our
recommendations for the repair template
and how to incorporate that desired
change the two main nuclea systems that
we're developing and working with at
thermo Fisher is the CRISPR cast 9
system which I imagine a large majority
of our audience members are already
familiar with briefly CRISPR cast 9
system is a bacterial adaptive immune
spawns pathway that consists of the cast
9 protein as well as a duplex of crispr
RNA and tracer RNA molecules the
specificity of the cleavage by cast line
is dictated by the crispr RNA sequence
this 20 nucleotide sequence that can be
designed to any part of the genome
assuming that it's next to a proto
spacer adjacent motif or a pam site
which is required to be next to that
crispr RNA sequence for streptococcus
pyogenes cast iron which is the most
predominant cast line we see scientists
using that pam site is ngg
when you design your guide RNA to be
specific to your target genomic loci and
it is adjacent to a Pam fight you'll get
cleavage three bases upstream of your
Pam site and this will produce blunt
ended DNA breaks and cast nine and these
guide RNA molecules are introduced into
eukaryotic cells neither a plasmid
format as RNA molecules using a cast
nine mRNA and aren't your guide RNA
molecules or as an RMP or
ribonucleoprotein format in which a
recombinant cast nine protein is complex
with a guide RNA in vitro and then that
team guide RNA complex is delivered into
yourself
the second nuclea system that we work
with our Tao activator like effector
nucleases or talent and talvez genome
editing uses these towel effector
proteins which have been engineered by
from bacteria to be specific DNA binding
proteins with functional domains fused
onto them the tau effector proteins
consist of repeat amino acid sequences
that work as multimers and get HIV with
gene specific DNA binding domain so the
DNA binding domain can be mutated and
designed to target any part of the
genome we then fuse these with
functional domains to give specific
activity and for tau effector nucleases
we fuse them with the phoque one and a
nucleus
pal ones will act as bait we'll use
towels as pairs and therefore you will
have a right hand and a left hand towel
and in combination with their to sock
one nucleases will cause a
double-stranded break which will leave
four base pair five prime overhangs
after cleaving and talent pairs can be
introduced into eukaryotic cells as
either plasmids or more recently we've
developed a means to make these as RNA
molecules and provide those as the
delivered material into cells now we
focus on talents specifically for genome
editing as they have a number of
advantages over the CRISPR system one
being is that there's no sequence
restrictions these DNA binding domains
can be designed to any part of the
genome and this and because of that
we're a lot talans allow us to get an
increased proximity to our desired
insertion sites we'll talk more about
that in some subsequent slides
we're cast 9 will have to be designed to
those proto stays proto spacer adjacent
motifs or be dependent on pam site
talent can be designed to cut at any
part of the genome and because of this
we do see improved homology directed
repair when using talons relative to
CRISPR now when we look at homology
directed repair and we've got our CRISPR
cast 9 or our Talon nuclease and it's
cleave the genome we need to be
introducing a donor DNA at the same time
that's going to have the appropriate
left and right homology arms flanking
our insertion site which will allow for
this new piece of DNA to be incorporated
into the genome and effectively cause a
knockin effect that we're looking for
either to add a reporter gene create a
fusion protein disrupt these functional
domain or change snips
and for this there's a number of
different types of donor templates that
a scientist could choose to use the
first is single-stranded DNA these are
generally less than 200 nucleotides long
and this is due to the kind of the
synthesis limit that we see for
commercially available custom DNA all of
those those generally cap out at 100
nucleotides and some vendors are able to
get that up to 200 nucleotides long
these single stranded DNA donors are
used to cause small changes those are
snip changes or amino acid changes or
small deletions in the genome
the second donor type will be
double-stranded DNA these are in the
range of 200 to 5,000 base pairs or 0.2
to 5 KB they can be sourced either as
linear plasmid fragments or generated by
PCR and these types of donors are chosen
if you're trying to do a gene insertion
create some sort of fusion protein or
add reporter constructs to your gene of
interest
next for even larger insertions some
type scientists will choose plasmid DNA
these are generally used for knock ends
from the one to ten context 1 to 10 KB
range although theoretically there is a
higher limit although the efficacy
becomes very limited plasmids fordham
for donor DNA are generally produced by
doing DNA synthesis some sort of sub
cloning into a propagation vector and
then purification of that plasmid from
host E coli and again these are done to
do larger gene insertions or add larger
reporter constructs and then the last
would be a viral vector and we're seeing
more scientists using a av viruses to
accomplish their knock ends these are
generally for insertions from one to
four point five KB and these are
produced by doing DNA synthesis sub
cloning into the viral vectors and going
through a viral production process and
these are generally done for larger gene
insertion and these have gained
advantage for some applications due the
fact that the virus can transduce the
cells and therefore serve as their own
delivery vehicle for our presentation
today and most of the Rd work that's
been done um that we've done has been
focusing on the single stranded and
double stranded DNA donor types
now when we talk about donor design what
the questions that we get from a number
of scientists that we go out and talk to
is they want to know how they should be
best designing this molecule how close
does my Pam site need to be to the
insertion site
how long did my homology are I've seen
to be how well does my guide RNA need to
cut should I be using single-stranded
versus a double-stranded donor and
collectively are the scientists that we
work with are asking can you help me
design my donor molecule what is this
donor molecule need to look like to be
successful so what we did as part of our
Rd group is we went to establish
consistent and simple rules for HD our
donor design we wanted to make sure that
we had a simple and easy-to-follow rule
set that was going to be consistent
across a wide variety of edits but it
didn't happen we don't have to rewrite
the rule set for each different type of
edit that someone may want to do we took
these rule sets and we developed a novel
design tool that we put on thermo Fisher
comm that has an intuitive user
interface that makes it easy for users
to design their own knockin experiments
and then we made this tool free and
available to all scientists so that we
can share this information and make sure
that it's applicable and accessible to
everyone
so to look at this data and kind of to
set up how we went about investigating
this we set up a number of different
experiments to kind of screen different
donor configurations and this first
experiment here is we generated a knock
in cell line that had a crippled GFP
protein put into its genome and what
happened here is that we have a the GFP
will require a six base insertion to
reproduce its fluorescence activity so
at this position zero here we're looking
to do a six base insertion and this will
activate GFP and the GFP protein will
now fluoresce across this GFP gene we
looked at a nut to identify all of our
guide RNA sites that are both 3 prime
and 5 prime of this insertion so as we
look across the 70 base pair region
we've got guide RNA that - 34-31 and all
the way up to plus 21 and plus 30 and
these are basically guide RNAs that are
going to have cut sites that are that
many bases away from our position zero
where we're trying to do the insertion
so we took all of these guide RNAs
across this entire region and screen
them for their cleavage efficiency and
we can see across the board that all
majority of these guys have endo
percentages greater than sixty percent
these guide RNAs are able to cut at
these different sites across this GFP
protein some of them perform less well
than others like this minus nineteen and
minus fourteen perform less well than we
see as the minus 31 or the minus twenty
and we've got some particularly poor
performing guides here at this plus 21
but overall we kind of have a different
array of guide RNA cleavage efficiency
now when we look at our percent GFP
positive cells or the cells that have
had successful and precise HDR occur we
see that the guys that were in closest
proximity to our insertion site so our
guides that are minus 7 - 3 + 3 + 5 + +
8 are giving us the highest knockin rate
relative of this panel if we look at
some of the more distal guide RNAs like
our minus 31 or our plus 30 we do see
some GFP repair there we do see some hgr
for those guys that are more distal but
it's significantly less than the guides
that are going to be within that close
proximity to our insertion site now
what's interesting about this is our
plus 3 we guide RNA we do see a certain
degree of knock in here but it's much
less than any of the neighboring ones
and this is likely due to the low
cleavage efficiency of that guide RNA so
to kind of summarize these data the rule
sets that we've developed and the
learnings we have from this is that we
would recommend using an insertion site
within 10 braces of the DNA break or
have your DNA or have your engineer
nucleus cut within 10 braces of your
intended insertion site and to use the
highest cleaving cast 9 guide RNA or the
highest cleaving nuclease available to
cut this particular low site and if you
want to see more of these data we have
all of this information and a couple
more experiments published in our
Journal of biotechnology are
which you can access via thermo Fisher
comm slash true design which has a link
out to the original paper which is an
open access and available for download
now we repeated this experiment doing
and something a little bit different now
with double-stranded donors to
understand if the same rules apply
so looking across this segment here we
are trying to do a knock in experiment
where we're knocking in a donor's
cassette that has a resistance marker a
self-cleaning p2a and then a GFP
reporter into the n-terminus of the act
B gene so we're trying to knock this in
immediately after our start codon and we
identified all of our guide RNAs across
this low sign and looked at the cleavage
efficiency for all of them and as you
can see in this graph over here we get
an about an average cleavage efficiency
of about sixty percent although guide
+19 clearly does not cut as we saw no
cleavage with that particular guide RNA
and then when we look at our percent GFP
positive cells again we see that the we
should get the highest percent GFP
positive cells when our cleavage site is
close to our insertion site so we see
the highest knockin rate with our plus
one and we see a decent amount with the
minus five there is some signal at the
minus twenty or minus twenty seven guide
RNA but again we're seeing over 50
percent GFP positive self at that plus
one cutting guide RNA now what's
interesting about this donor as this
does have a resistance marker for Purim
Ison selection on it is that we can
apply paralyzing selection to all of
these cells and we see that we can pull
these populations up to being greater
than 80 percent GFP positive so even our
cells that were cut with the minus
twenty seven guide RNA and we're getting
less than 1% knockin we can pull that
population to being 80 percent GFP
positive by applying this puro myosin
selection and importantly our minus
nineteen guide which has zero cleavage
efficiency basically this guide RNA does
not work all those kind of stores our
negative control here and we've got no
signal either with or without puro
myosin and we'll kind of touch on
this system a little bit more in later
slides but again kind of reinforce it
here of using an earth have your DNA
break within ten basis of your intended
insertion site
now if you're looking to model sniff
changes you have are going to have a
very precise location where you're going
to want to have this genome editing
occur and this might be difficult to do
with CRISPR cast line if you're looking
at something that's in a Pam desert so
what we have here in this table are a
number of annotated snip changes in the
bracket one gene exon 11 which is known
to be new oncogenic and an important low
sign for a lot of oncology studies and
if we look at exon 11 here and try to
identify the snip that we can edit with
genome editing we realize that there's
very good with CRISPR cast 9 we realized
that there's a limited number that are
actually accessible by CRISPR cast 9
base knock in if we screen out part of
this gn8 or this DNA for pam sites that
are within 10 bases of the snip we
actually lose a large part of this
genome because there's no pam sites that
are going to be available to work with
the CRISPR cast 9 system for the ones
that do or do remain and we look for
high-efficiency cutting or basically
high cutting guys we also eliminate
another area of this region and if we
remove guides that have off targets
we've actually excluded a large part of
this exon 11 that's going to be editable
by cast 9 and again this is due to that
pam desert the low number of ngg sites
that exist within this sequence and
overall 70 percent of this region is
inaccessible by CRISPR cast 9 for
successful knock and editing so what
would you do if you're trying to model a
snip change that exists in a Pam desert
so looking at another model snip that
exists in a pam desert this pik 3 are
our 3 48 missense mutation nonsense
mutation excuse me state change we
identified on CRISPR cast 9 cut sites
that are going to be able to reproduce
this specific snip change and we see
that there's two guides that are
available at the - 17 and minus 20
position and when we look at our precise
HDR for this - 17 guide we see that we
get less than 1% knockin rate using
CRISPR cast 9 and that
guide RNA to try to do that specific
snip now for this particular exon in
this particular region where we're
trying to do this a data conversion to
cause this you know typically to me
change the genome here that minus 20 and
7 minus 17 are the only two guides that
are within this area that we could try
to do on this particular knockin but if
we design these with talents and we can
design this talent pair to cut
specifically at that snip site we're
actually able to get an HDR our precise
HDR knockin greater than forty percent
because we're able to target these towns
specifically to that snip site and
encourage successful HDR we also get a
certain degree of HDR with air where
we're getting imperfect junctions or the
five or the three prime of that
insertion so basically we had HDR occur
here but we did not get the snip change
that we are intending to and overall we
see the total HDR rate being around 50
percent when we look at our ndele
frequency so basically every all the
types of edits that occurred from having
a double-stranded break but did not take
up a donor and did not have HDR we see
that the end-all rates actually pretty
high for our CRISPR cast nine system so
this guide RNA is cutting it is an
effective guide RNA for causing cleavage
at that site but it doesn't effectively
take up this donor molecule and get the
successful HDR and then the remaining
fraction for both these experiments is
going to be wild-type alleles that were
on edited or remained unchanged after
the CRISPR cast night or Talent mediated
editing
and again something to keep in mind here
is that this guide RNA is
well-performing we do see greater than
60% cleavage or in delft formation for
this guide RNA despite having no HDR
now when we try to normalize this a
little bit we are going to design talons
and crispers to cut the same site we we
continue to see Talentum being more
efficient and having precise HDR than
CRISPR so for this example we looked at
a a vs1 and identified guide RNAs that
would be cleaving at this low side and
then design talent pairs that would cut
at the same site so basically we
identified crispers and then we designed
a talent pair that would be cutting at
that same low sy and then try to do a
knock in there and for this we see that
our precise HDR is about 40% for talent
and less than 20% for CRISPR so we have
a significant improvement in our HD ra
when we choose talents our HDR with air
is pretty similar with both tools and
our end lr8 kind of fills out the rest
of this fraction where we have a higher
fraction of in Dells occurring with
CRISPR relative to talent and again here
our guide RNA is working pretty well
actually both of these tools are
cleaving at about 90% at this low sign
but we get a higher fraction of precise
HDR with talent than we do with CRISPR
and if we look at other low site as well
like I excuse me ip3 r2 and we do the
same kind of design we see that talons
will outperform CRISPR in terms of the
total per site or the fraction of
precise HDR in the cells pop these cell
populations after editing if we look at
a summary of these data comparing
crisper and talons we can see that kind
of across the board here looking at a
number of different targets we have some
high-performing CRISPR cast nine designs
we're getting total editing greater than
90 percent for a number of these but the
HDR rate either precise HDR or HDR with
air is less than 30 percent across the
board with some of these having very
little to no HDR successfully occurring
but if we look at a similar panel of
Talon based genome editing we see that
our precise HDR is greater than twenty
percent almost across the board we have
some fraction of HDR with air and our
total in Dell frequency is
difficult ly less so overall our talons
are able to give us a higher rate of HDR
and can be a more effective tool for NOC
and editing
as these have proven to be a useful tool
for not in editing we've recently
developed an Talent mRNA production
service to make ready to use talent
mRNAs for genome editing and again here
some data summarized demonstrating the
percent HDR improvement with talons
versus CRISPR we we have now developed a
service that can allow users to get
access to this technology easier and the
way that this works is that we will take
the sequences the sequence of the genome
that you're looking to edit to we will
generate constructs to produce those
talons that would cut at that specific
low sign and then we will perform an in
vitro transcription and RNA purification
off of that plasmid contract that we
make and provide ready to transfer
talent mRNA for genome editing purposes
and if you're interested in learning
more about this cow mRNA production
service I encourage you to reach out to
your local rep or you can email our
services lab directly at gem services at
thermo Fisher comm
now going back to donor design kind of
the last outstanding question that we
really wanted to test here was to
determine the minimum donor arm
a donor homology arm link that's needed
and if you look at more dogmatic
approaches to genome editing in the
literature you're going to see
recommendations for single-stranded DNA
having at least 50 nucleotide homology
arms on either side of your edit but
what we know from single-stranded DNA
and how these are produced is that long
oligos are going to have a lower
synthesis synthesis efficacy or
efficiency and become more expensive the
longer than they get longer that they
get and when you look at double-stranded
DNA that recommendation ends up being
about 500 base pairs or more and when
you're trying to create homology arms
that are going to be 500 base pairs or
more you're now talking about either
going through a gene synthesis pathway
and having it made synthetically or
you're talking about a multi fragment
cloning to piece all these together as
you're going to need a left homology arm
and or write homology arm and your
reporter sequence all ligated together
into one larger cloning complex so what
we decided to do is create a library of
donors that are going to have
increasingly smaller donor donor arms
and test what's the minimum homology arm
length that's needed for a successful
nock in
and so for this first experiment with
single-stranded DNA we created donors
that had a flag in Co r1 insertion and
then different homology arm links going
from 45 down to 15 nucleotides long and
what we see here is that when we're
using 15 nucleotide homology rhymes we
get very little knock in a rate this
percent knockin is pretty low when we go
to 24 percent we see that 24 nucleotides
long we see that improve to close to 20
percent and when we go to 30 nucleotides
are longer and we see that kind of
plateauing out or if you had at least 30
nucleotide of homology arms or greater
you kind of get the max knockin rate
that you're going to get with just kind
of these donut design characteristics
when you look at double-stranded DNA you
do a similar experiment but we're
working with a little bit longer arms we
see that at those short donor arms at 12
or 21 nucleotides we get low knockin
rate but when you get to 35 or higher
that again starts to Plateau we see a
similar effect if you're using
single-stranded or double stranded DNA
where there seems to be a bit of a
sealing here that you reach and longer
homology arms don't necessarily add any
benefit despite the increased level of
effort that might be needed to produce
longer homology our molecules so this
leads to our last rule on for effective
donor design which is to use homology
arms that are at least 30 to 35
nucleotides long as these are sufficient
to get effective knockin
so with all of that we now have our
three simple rules for HDR donor design
one have your DNA break within ten basis
of your desired edit site so choosing a
nucleus that's going to be able to give
you that cut less than ten base pairs
away from where you're trying to change
the genome to use the most efficient
enzyme possible whether that's CRISPR
task 9 or tile sector nucleases to give
you that high cleavage rate at your
desired low sign and three include at
minimum thirty nucleotide homology arms
on either side of your desire change on
your donor and so with these three
simple rules we wanted to make this
accessible and effortless for scientists
to use these rules for designing various
donors and so what we did is we
developed a new platform that we're
calling our true design G no matter to
design genome editor that's now
available on thermo Fisher comm and what
we did here is we made a software
platform that allows you to search for
your gene we've got the human genome
loaded here that allow and allow you to
search up any transcript and modify it
as you wish once you've searched for
your transcripts and identified your
gene you can then go ahead and craft
your edit and do specific changes to the
DNA sequence and change specific amino
acids and then lastly the tool go ahead
and complete the design it'll take in
the design criteria that you've given it
the insertions deletions tags you want
to add and then it'll go ahead and
design the appropriate CRISPR cast nine
guide RNAs or the Tala factor nucleases
that are going to be needed to generate
the cut at that fight as well as design
the donor molecule that will be needed
to accomplish that knockin in the lab
and with that I'm going to do a quick
walkthrough of our true design tool
again this is live on thermo Fisher comm
right now the first thing that you would
do as a user is you will then search for
your gene of interest we currently have
this loaded with the human genome and we
will be loading additional genomes into
this tool throughout 2020 but once you
search for your gene name for example
here I've got the rel aging you'll be
displayed with all of the various
transcripts for this particular gene and
once you select the transcript you're
looking to edit we will then display
this gene in a topology format showing
you the introns the exons and
untranslated regions for this gene and
then you'll be able to view the specific
DNA sequence as well as the amino acids
for this particular protein close up and
then you're able to point and click and
edit the genome as needed for your
specific knockin so what I have on the
sequence viewer here is we are looking
at the c-terminus of the r-la gene I put
my cursor between that final serine and
the stop codon here and then what I've
told the tool I want to do is I want to
insert this 24 nucleotide sequence into
the rel aging before our stop codon to
create a fusion tag here and then once I
click insert the tool will refresh and
it'll show this new sequence that I've
inserted excuse me at the c-terminus
of the rel aging here and now I've added
these eight additional amino acids for
the flag tag arm before the stock codon
of r-la once I've completed crafting the
edit that I want to accomplish the tool
will go ahead and design various CRISPR
sequences and talent sequences that can
cause cleavage at this site as well as
design a donor molecule that would be
needed to accomplish this particular
edit so what the tool is showing here is
a various CRISPR cast line guide RNA
sequences and where they cut as well as
pairs of talyn's that cannot cause that
can excuse me do equivalent editing at
this site now
remember when we talked about for the
donors we have those homology arms of 30
nucleotide you Cleo ties long so what we
have here is our donor molecule relative
to the original DNA with both our left
and right minimal homology arms flanking
that flag tag sequence that we've
inserted when you're done doing your
design all of the information your guide
RNA sequences the talent sequences the
donor for the oligo donor sequence
sequencing primers are all available and
a comprehensive download and therefore
kind of compiling all of the information
that you would need to accomplish this
edit in your lab we're going to be
continuing to develop this platform
throughout 2020 including different edit
types as well as connecting this with
our thermo Fisher kaam karte system
making it easier to obtain all of these
materials on in one click
so at the beginning of our presentation
we talked about the required materials
for knockin though first was going to be
a specific specific and efficient
nuclease system and what that true
design will recommend either our crisper
cast line products our true cut cast
line and synthetic guide rnas or talent
pairs depending on the type of edit
you're wanting to do and the design
restrictions that may apply to that
specific part of the genome it will then
give you the repair template with your
desired change like we talked about it's
got our our single stranded DNA au logo
here that would be recommended it's for
displayed as double stranded DNA to
describe what it would look like and
it's we've got our left and right
homology arms here and then three of
methods of the liver in the cells and
the tool will recommend you either life
effect amine CRISPR max if you've chosen
to go down a crisper cast 9 editing
pathway or life effect amine messenger
max if you're going to be using the
talent mRNA pairs and so what true
design here is kind of piecing all of
these materials together to give you a
comprehensive solution for not in genome
editing and give you all the tools that
are needed to have a successful
experiment
with that we're going to pivot a little
bit and talk about how we can drive this
knock inefficiency to be even higher
using our true Tag donor DNA system so
earlier in the talk we talked about
knocking in a gfp fusion into the
n-terminus of the ACT b gene and we
scanned along all of the various guide
rnas across this exon two of act B we
looked at their cleavage efficiencies
here and then I showed you a graph where
we show that the highest knockin rate
was going to be at that minus 5 and plus
1 guide but what I also showed you was
that if you apply a pure myosin
selection to these cells that are edited
with this donor that has a resistance
marker in here we're able to pull all of
these populations up to 80% GFP positive
cells and applying this selective
pressure dramatically improves the
percent edited cell as we're selectively
excluding some that did not have
successful knock in here
so even cells that had a poor knockin
rate had 1% you know knock in like our
minus 27 guide RNA we're able to pull
that population up to be greater than 80
percent GFP positive self by applying
this selection and so to kind of look at
this a little bit further and how we can
apply this and make this flexible we try
to look at tagging genes at their n + C
terminus so looking at true design
genome editor here and looking at the
act B gene we made designs for
n-terminal knock ins and c-terminal
knockin and what we were able to do is
we're able to show that we we could make
GFP fusions at the end terminus or the C
terminus of the ACT B gene and make GFP
fusion proteins so what we're looking at
here is we've got you 200 s cells that
have been selected for with puro myosin
there are about a couple days into the
selective process but you can see that
we've got nice actin filaments forming
in these u2s cells that are visible
because they're gfp fusion proteins and
this is Kapus we can achieve this at the
end terminus or the c terminus of Act V
gene and when we look to quantify this
either with or without Pyramus and
selection we can see that when we apply
pure Meissen selection to the n-terminus
fusion we're able to drive that
population to greater than 80% and when
we do this at the c-terminus we're able
to drive us to being greater than 99
to send positive GFP cells so the
Selective pressure here really allows us
to get a purified not in cell population
without going through any kind of clonal
cell isolation process and having a
really purified cell pool that's all
knock in positive cells
when we look at this is kind of like a
time course on our day 0 we have 0 gfp
positive cell because they haven't been
knocked in yet but we're preparing our
donor DNA we're delivering it into the
cells if we look after day 3 or 4 we
start to visualize and we're able to see
GFP positive cells the knockin has
occurred the DNA has been repaired this
fusion protein is now being expressed we
now have a number of act B GFP Mollick
from GF P molecules in the cell and
therefore we see GFP positive cells and
about 25% of these cells are gfp
positive at this point we start to apply
our selective marker here and we're
therefore killing off cells that don't
have that p.m. ice and resistance
cassette and at day 10 we now have a
stable cell pool that's greater than 99%
GFP positive cells so we're able to
create a very pure cell population that
are all knock in positive taking this
beyond the act be example we also
attempt to tag a number of different
genes and different sub cellular
compartments looking at proteins like
laminin and the nucleus looking at
mitochondrial proteins like ATP 5 be
looking at cytosol ik proteins like in
addition to acne such as CCP 3 and
microtubules like looking at tubulin and
across the board with or without pyramus
and selection we're able to see these
fusion proteins were able to
successfully knock these in in frame
getting proper junctions and make
effective fusion proteins using these
true tag designs
we also trip to tag and combine it with
an rfp protein instead of just GFP and
so what we were able to do here is start
to do a couple different like dual
stains type experiments so for this
example we've got a histone protein with
GFP and then we've got our SP on our
actin lo site as well
and then when we dual tag these in 2 9 3
cells we can see our histone GFP protein
in the nucleus we've got the RSP actin
in the cytoplasm and when we do a merge
of all these we can see appropriate
co-localization receiving appropriate
compartmentalization of the nuclear
versus cytoplasmic signal of these
various fusion proteins so we can see
here in our far right hand side that
merge where we've got red cytoplasmic
and green nuclear signal creating kind
of you know interesting and unique cell
models by knockin genome editing
so true tag donors are generated by PCR
as we're using these 30 nucleotide
homology arms we're able to do this and
make these donor cassettes specific for
any gene of interest by PCR so you'll
have to take your forward primer and a
reverse primer that are going to be have
consistent regions for the donor
template and then you customize the 5
prime end of those primers to be
specific to your gene and the true
design platform actually has a tool for
designing true tagged primers once you
go through the PCR and column cleanup
you then have a transfection ready donor
that's going to have your left and right
homology arms at it flanking your
insertion which is the reporter p2a
resistance marker contract and this
entire process for making this donor
we've reduced to being less than 3 hours
and includes no cloning steps
so kind of
summary for this a little bit we have
our new true Tag donor DNA systems and
this allows you to get greater than 99%
at itself we currently have solutions
for GFP RFP and luciferase fusion
proteins and you can generate your donor
molecule in less than three hours each
of these kits includes four different
donor templates - for doing n-terminal
tagging or - for doing c-terminal
tagging with Pyramus and/or blasts
assigned resistance proteins and the kit
also includes PCR master mix for
producing your donor again doing that
piece here to add the homology arms
includes a cleanup module for cleaning
up the DNA prior to transmission and we
include positive control primers for act
B so that you can reproduce that act the
example that I showed at the beginning
here we were able to get greater than
50% knockin at the n-terminus
arm of act be using the true tag system
so the primers for that particular
design are included with each system
so moving into our last bit here we are
going to talk about two case studies
where we're looking at pluripotent stem
cells and T cells and the true tag donor
DNA system so working with our stem cell
colleagues who are looking to develop
model develop models for studying fate
determination on pluripotent stem cells
we designed an experiment where we're
going to take I P SC s we would edit
them with our true cut cast nine a
single guide RNA and true tag donors
apply selection for ten days we then
have a true tag on PSC population so
horse bone stem cells that have been
edited to be gia or to be true tag
knocked in we would differentiate these
into neural stem cells and then
ultimately terminally differentiate
these into astrocytes and so what we did
for this astrocytes specific experiment
is we decided we were going to tag the G
fat protein which is neat which is
expressed in astrocytes but not in
neural stem cell and not in pluripotent
stem cells and for this we chose to do
something a little bit different and do
a C terminal knock in so what we did
before the stop codon is we designed a
new donor that would have again those
minimal left and right homology arms
our reporter sequence and then its own
promoter for the resistance marker and
what this does is allows us to make a G
fat GFP fusion but since the resistance
marker has it as an exogenous promoter
it can be selected for independently at
G fab expression which means we can
select for these knock and when they're
in the pluripotent stem cell phase and
not just at the differentiation of the
differentiated phase so what we did is
we made our true tag IPS C cells and we
can see here under fluorescent and
bright field that these are not GFP
positive at this time we went through
our neural induction into NSC s and then
we went into our astrocyte
differentiation and after about 18 days
of going through astrocyte
differentiation we start to see a gfp
signal we've got less than 1% cells
being GFP positive at this time
member they're moving from being a
neural stem cell into an astrocyte so
we're starting to see some of that GFP
signal turn on and when we get to about
day 45 of differentiation greater than
90 percent of ourselves our GFP positive
showing that we successfully knocked in
on to something that's only being
expressed in our astrocytes
the second thing we did was then to
confirm if we successfully tagged G SAP
and went wasn't just being turned on
nonspecifically
in an astrocyte like so so what we did
is we looked for our G fat EMG SP signal
we then stain the cells for the G SAP
antibody and when we do our overlay on
the far right hand side we see really
nice co-localization of the EMG F P
signal and the G fab antibody signal
showing that we're getting specific
tagging and specific fusions made of the
G fat protein with our gfp donor again
demonstrating how we can do a knock in
at the pluripotent stem cell phase and
then keep this appropriate reporter
signal at the differentiation point into
astrocytes
for our second example we're going to be
talking about primary t-cells and it's
been a really important week we've had a
number of conversations with scientists
about the importance of having complete
solutions for t-cell editing especially
when we talk about Carty development and
looking to use these you use genome
editing and immuno oncology to make
therapies and so what we've done here
for this general workflow is that we're
able to isolate and activate T cells
using Dyna beat based kits that are able
to purify these cells from donor cell
populations and activate the T cells we
can then do a t-cell transfection using
our true cut cast 9 and our guide RNA as
well as the true Tag donor DNA system in
the neon and then after 48 hours you're
able to assess the cleavage efficiency
as well as any functional changes to the
cells by either looking for our GFP
reporters in the true tag system as well
as looking for cell surface proteins
that were editing so for this example
what we did here again we isolated an
activated dynabeads we then did our
t-cell transaction and then we're
analyzing them with agus tune NXT flow
cytometer and if we look at the left
hand side with our untranslated sample
we see that our t-cell population that
we're starting with is about 92% PCR
positive and if we go in with guide RNAs
against the alpha or beta chain of the
t-cell receptor we see that we're able
to knock out that TCR signal by gulten
94 confuse me by 94% or greater
um when we're targeting either the alpha
or the beta chain of the t-cell receptor
gene so if we look at this example in
the middle graph here we're seeing that
there's about 2% cells remaining PCR
positive and when we look at the beta
chain we're seeing about 7 percent cells
remaining t-cell positive but overall
using either of these guys we're able to
demonstrate a greater than 92 percent
functional knockout of the t-cell
receptor with our workflow
when we look at donor drive mm donor
knock in we're able to knock in the true
tag system again looking at this act B
model here and we're able to knock this
in into the act v locus of these T cells
and we see with our buffer R that's
included with the neon system about a 5%
GFP positive cells and buffer c-17 which
was currently under development to
improve our knocking or improve our
transaction systems and improve our
knockin we see that actually increasing
to about 29% GSP positive looking at a
second locus there at 11 a locus it's a
similar story or using buffer our were
able to be at about 30% GFP positive
cells and with our buffer C 17 that
we're currently developing we see about
a 15% improvement and that as well um
demonstrating kind of this model for
developing new tools for genome editing
in T cells as well as delivery of
materials into T cells so we talked
about knock out and knock in here and so
for this last experiment we really tried
to piece it all together so if we look
on the plot on our left hand side here
our control we've got 96 percent of
ourselves being PCR positive and when we
go ahead and do our knockout only we get
about a 93 percent TCR knockout we do a
combination of knockout and knock in
using the buffer R and a gfp donor we
see about a 94% TCR knockout and a 6
percent gfp knockin and when we do this
with the beat buffer c---seventeen that
we're developing we see about a 94% TCR
knockout and close to 30 percent gfp
positive self so again we're able to
demonstrate kind of the combinatorial
nature of knockouts and knock ins in T
cells really getting to the promise of
engineer T cells for various therapeutic
applications using these combination of
editing tools
so in summary for this presentation we
reviewed knocking genome editing we
talked about the basics of CRISPR cast 9
as well as tala section nucleases I then
went through and presented the rules for
successful HCR donor design and rnd data
that was used to generate this rule set
we talked about the true design tool and
how you can use that today to design
your own NOC and experiments to create
snip changes or amino acid changes or
introduce it to a true tag into your
system number 4 we showed you how to
obtain 100 up to 100 percent edited
cells using true tag donors and applying
selective pressure to pull those nokton
cell populations up to 100% edited and
then lastly we apply to tag donors to
pluripotent stem cells and T cells again
demonstrating the versatility of these
various knockin methodologies and with
that I thank you all for your attention
and I believe we will now open it up for
the live Q&A
you
oh thank you very much Matt that was
great we had a lot of questions come in
so we will get to those right away if
you still have a question you'd like to
ask you can do so just click on the ask
a question box located on the far left
of your screen ok Matt our first
question came in kind of early in the
presentation so you might have already
addressed it but the question is what's
the maximum length of the insertion
sequence right great questions so for
the true tag system we are working with
donors with a maximum length of about
1.5 KB and that's where we've done most
of our development work around the
double-stranded donors in that
configuration we're looking at that 1.5
may be 1.6 KB in length arm our services
team have done knock ins up to 5 KB arm
for custom projects for for our
different scientists but the development
work that we focused on here is going to
be about 1.5 KB size are smaller and
then for the single-stranded donors that
we talked a lot about to the maximum
insertion site that we've played with
there's about 30 base pairs of insertion
when using a single stranded donor
so if you're using single stranded DNA
we're looking at about 30 bases and
double stranded donor we're looking
about a total of 1.5 KB insertion okay
next question do you observe differences
and guide RNA efficiency or the same
target depending on the cell type
depending on the cell type so in general
there will be cell to cell differences
in guide RNA cutting but the trends
generally remain the same if you've got
a well performing guide and cell type a
it'll generally generally be a well
performing guide and cell type B and the
same will be the true for poor
performing guides if it's not cutting
well in one cell line it's probably not
going to cut well on your other cell
lines arm the absolute cutting
efficiency for a particular guide will
vary from cell to cell um and that's
generally dependent on the overall
delivery efficiency how well you can get
that cast 9 and guide RNA complex into
yourselves um as well as small changes
can kind of like chromatin compromise or
configuration and depending on the cell
type but the trends remain the same from
cell line to cell line so make sense
okay um this next question I believe is
looking to address the the talent or the
crisper approaches that you talked about
four nucleus cleavage it's asking which
technology has a lower off target rate
so it's going to that's a design
specific question for crispers or talons
now the benefit kind of the the overall
recommendation is that talons will have
more specificity as you do require a
pair of design nucleases to come
together at a specific spot that cause a
double-stranded break since you need
that pairing the right and the left
talon you are adding a certain degree of
specificity there which would reduce
your overall off-target profile because
you would need that exact pairing of 22
nucleotides to be within five bases of
each other in multiple parts of the
genome to get off target events to occur
now you know where you wanted them to
versus CRISPR where you're just looking
looking at that twenty nucleotide
sequence down pretty thin yeah exactly
and then yeah yeah and then so for
CRISPR obviously working about twenty
nucleotide sequence so there is a higher
likelihood of that occurring and then
also there's since it's a DNA base
pairing you can get blebs
or you know bubbles forming between the
RNA DNA duplex and that can also lead to
some off-target specificity but it does
again depend on the target and where
you're looking to cause the cut to make
like an absolute you know recommendation
of an off target profile right so next
question there there's actually two that
all kind of ask you at the same time
they both have to do with the true guide
design tool the true design tool yeah oh
god sorry yeah true disease no worries
any truth the true design tool yes the
first part is what if I want to design
and not going to experiment for
something other than human and then
along the same lines do you plan to
expand your knockin software to
non-coding regions
okay gotcha so yes the current design
tool true design is loaded with the
human genome we are still in development
of that tool to build out additional
features so we are planning on adding
additional genomes specifically mouse at
least in within 2020 and we're looking
to add like rats zebrafish
some other model organisms to true
design platform over the next couple
months into non-coding regions that's
something that we have talked about with
the development team on and we're
looking to understand what that would
need to look like from a user UI
experience to enable editing and
non-coding regions but it's something
that's definitely been on our roadmap of
what we'd like to take this tool I can
see what the question might be how do
you orient yourself without you know
exon intron boundaries or you know kind
of yeah exactly and a lot of what we
talked about when I showed in those
screenshots is we're really trying to
help users orient themselves in the
genome so they can make a specific edit
um and we've anchored that a lot around
the exon intron boundaries so if we are
going into a non-coding region we don't
have that same kind of landmarks and
orientations to put the user in on so
we're trying to figure out kind of the
best way we would solution for that and
then once we come up with that we'll be
able to support that kind of edit type
right right okay so this one has to do
with the the true tag kit and the
resistance or selection insert so the
pure Meissen be moved after initial
knockin so I guess kind of getting a
clean signal only without the resistance
yes so there's there's two ways that a
user could kind of solve for that one as
the donor so the donor templates that
are provided in the kit obviously have
the you know your reporter and the
pyramus and selection or blast assign
reflection marker you can design those
donors to omit that as it is just a PCR
you can design your primer to kind of
skip over that purim isin or blastocyte
and resistance marker and just amplify
and add homology arms to just the GFP or
just the RFP so you could do your
knockin without the Pyramus and
Pyrrha Meisner blast assign resistance
cassette at all if you so choose now you
won't be able to do any selected on that
front since it won't exist in yourself
but if you were worried about that and
just wanted to use the GFP part you
absolutely could do that the second is
that our C terminal donors arm have loxp
sites flanking the Pyramus and/or
blastocyte and resistance so if you're
doing a C terminal knockin you could do
a second transection with Cree
recombinase and cut out that Pierrot
Meissen or glassess I and Cosette using
Cree loxp recombination to remove that
arm from your you know your purified
salt or your cell line that you've made
that and you no longer need that
Selective pressure to be applied you
could do that as well to remove the the
Pyramus or blasts deciding okay I'm
going to try and squeeze in a couple
more here not or you're knocking are you
sequencing the results to check for
errors in the junctions yes so when we
did the development and and we're
looking at the true tag system as well
as a lot of those snip experiments that
I showed you with talons we were doing
sequencing to get the fraction of you
know perfect HDR HDR with air in Dells I
was all sequencing data and so for those
snips we were looking for basically the
perfect repair of that snip or those
base insertions and when we did our true
tag product development we also did
sequencing of that to look for um you
know how well those junctions are
occurring at the five prime three prime
end and overall the vast majority we
were seeing eighty five percent or
higher being having having perfect
junctions so them being integrated
appropriately and then also you have to
keep in mind is that since we're making
fusion proteins and we're running this
all on one open reading frame is that
you have to get perfect junctions at the
you know the five prime in there to get
expression of the GFP and expression of
the resistance because that if they're
imperfect junctions that cause frame
ships you won't see their GFP signal and
you won't be able to do any kind of
selection so any cells that have
imperfect junctions are going to be
selected against okay I'm going to
squeeze in one more question but I'm
sorry alright two-part question okay it
came in
when you were talking about the
stem-cell experiment okay they asked if
it's a stem cell specific promoter if so
which one was used oh yes okay so that
donor that we showed for the IPS see in
the astrocytes so that's using an EF one
alpha short promoter so it's oh right
it's not a stem cell specific promoter
it's a promoter that should be expressed
in a wide majority of cell types and the
idea is we want that promoter to be on
when the cells are still not
differentiated but for us to be able to
continue apply selective pressure or
choose to apply selective pressure at
any of our differentiation stages so we
chose something that should be least
somewhat ubiquitous to a lot of cell
types to make that design applicable to
two different experiments and then the
second question around that experiment
was whether the donors that you
discussed is available in the current
kit oh yes so that is that donor design
is kind of part of the second phase of
our development it's not currently
available in the kits that we talked
about we're still building that out and
doing additional validations on those
particular designs um but that's
something that we're looking to make
more widely available in the future um
if you were interested in today we can
support that through our custom services
arm and so that can be a conversation
with your local wrapping or you can
contact us at the the gem services at
thermo Fisher comm address if you're
interested in getting those materials
okay excellent well we are at the top of
the hour so before we wrap up completely
I want to thank you one more time Matt
for the great presentation and then of
course thank our audience for joining us
today as I said in the opening questions
that we didn't have time to answer live
I noticed that a lot came in just in the
last few minutes of the oh yeah lot
there yeah we will be addressing these
by email dirt for the with the address
that you provide at the time of
registration we'd also like to thank lab
roots and our sponsors Thermo Fisher
Scientific for underwriting today's
educational webcast many of you have
also asked
about future viewing of this it will be
viewable on demand so lab routes will
alert you by email when it's available
for for replay so we'd encourage you
obviously to watch it again or share it
share the email with your colleagues who
may have missed today's live event and
with that we'll wrap up I thank you
again for joining and hope everyone has
a great day